à l'époque on peut emporter qu'on peut
corner qu'on peut plier dans sa poche
même allant vers 1953
le livre de poche arrive en france
lancée par les éditions hachette
il s'inspire du pocket book de la taille
de la poche d'un jihai américain à ceci
près que le livre au lieu d'avoir son
dos dans sa partie la plus longue avait
son dos dans la partie la plus courte
afin qu'ils puissent l'entrée dans leurs
poches sans corner le livre sent déchiré
les feuilles la lecture devient
abordable le livre coûte de francs mais
cette démocratisation ne fait pas
l'unanimité comme pour ses étudiants
1964 que le livre de poche c'est un peu
comme un bouffon au papier on lit puis
après on met dans un coin vous pensez
vous du livre de paul beaucoup de marle
pourquoi est-ce que ça fait lire un peu
plus de gens qui n'avaient pas besoin de
cuire finalement toujours est il que le
livre de poche et en succès 8 millions
de ventes en 1958 28 millions de ventes
en 1968 depuis que l'hypothèse du dopage
vous en lisez vous plaît
livre de poche sortent des classiques
que dans la chute d'un lit brenna les
collections de la pléiade qui sont trop
chers toutous les pda les prix les prix
goncourt et quand ils sortent ils sont
trop chers
ça me permet de lire dans le métro ou
dans le train des choses comme ça en
prenait
et du côté des auteurs ils se
réjouissent de ce nouveau moyen d'accès
à la culture comme marcel pagnol en 1964
on vient de me dire que rimbaud à dire à
120 milles vers la gauche y attirer h en
20007 un moyen de culture qui est
presque aussi puissant que la radio ou
la télévision
aujourd'hui le livre de poche c'est un
catalogue de plus de 2000 auteurs et
plus d'un milliard d'exemplaires vendus
depuis sa création
[Musique]